[音楽]
うー
こんにちははじめ社長です
[音楽]
学風場ですあの今日は4月の1日という
ことでエイプリルフールということで
勘違いされる方も多いと思うんですけれど
も
実は本当のことだけを話しさせていただき
ます
動画のタイトルにもある通りですねええ
全部動画をです動画を
全部
聞かせていただきます
進撃の巨人の
します
ですよねぇーあと a ぶりルールという
ことでタイトルだけだけ進撃の巨人という
言葉を隠させていただいたんですけども
あの進撃の巨人肇社長2のチャンネルに
ファイナルシーズンまでの75
第一話から75でてるんですけれども
すべて種公開にさせていただくことになり
ますはいこれはもうもともと決まっていた
ことでしてあのやっぱ関係塩とかその権利
増の問題とか色々あって進撃の巨人の動画
市場から75はすべて
消えますのでいや普通にあの俺はメイン級
のことだと思って歌って新規なぁ分かって
ますみなさんアニメなんですよかみーやね
べなんですよ進撃の巨人神屋根目がはじめ
冊を2という一人の u 2バグ
チャンネルに出させていただいてそれは
こんな長い期間犯されていただいている
こと辞典もう汽笛のようがことで感謝しか
ないんです本当に進撃の巨人の関係者の皆
さん本当にありがとうございますそして数
3節を2で進撃の巨人を見てくださった皆
様も本当にありがとうございます
で式度もいつまでも見れるわけではないと
いうことで近々はじめシャツを2から進撃
の巨人がすべてキールということを
あのまあ消える俺これなんかエイプリル
フールの本当は俺の道が全部消えるみたい
な見せ方ができるんじゃねを騙せるんじゃ
にとレギュラーの全部消えるという
タイトルだよねちょっとだけ嘘付かされた
方へへへへへというわけで具体的にいつ
全部消えるかといいますと4月の4日の
月曜日の12時に異性に飛行回させて
いただきますもう響きを無料で皆さん進撃
の巨人が市場から75は見れてる時点の
軌跡その奇跡が4月の4日まであったって
ことですいやもありえないですよいや
ほんとにありがたいし色んな視聴者さん
ますこれを見て進撃の巨人に興味を持ち
ましたとか面白いとか言ってくださって
あの本本当に神奇跡的な最高の取り組みに
参加させていただいたなって思っており
ます
皆さんファイナルシーズン見てます76 y
1個は今テレビでやってるんですけど
やばいよねもう僕を毎週見てるんですけど
もなんとですね進撃の巨人のファイナル
シーズンのぱっつのラット87はが前日の
4月の3日シェアとの3日日曜日のに14
時5分4月に4日ね4月の4日の0時5分
からスタートなのですごい奇跡的な
タイミングで非公開になるという感じで
もう長い間す2においてもらえただけだ何
回も言ってるわけ面でもいいけど本当にも
感謝いっぱいですもなのでいつ今日金曜日
でしょ金と日そして月曜日後月4日9月
曜日の中ネジお昼のずう2時までは進撃の
巨人公開されておりますのでもう見れない
よ多分わからんけど何があるか分からん
けどて初17これファイナルシーズン本当
に完結できるからというペースだから
ちょっとだ不安なんて俺も全くわかんない
けどねこれアニメファイナルシーズンで
全部いけるかなって言うからわかんないん
ですけどもまあひとまず市場から75
はんなり社長2で出ているのは4月の床を
蹴るで消え末までぜひみなさんこの金融の
夜そして土曜日日曜日で日曜日夜には
アイドルシーズンの最終話買ってます
テレビでそして月曜日のを切るには全て
消えますのでまっさらとぜひをはじめ
シャツを2で洗練するのではなく俺はこの
名チャンネルにエイプリルフールを利用し
てもみんなに進撃の巨人のすばらしさを
伝えたかったということでなんかちょっと
ウルッときて決まりました終わっちゃめの
発信いけない巨人が
安心院簿最終話ですので5シーズンのぜひ
ともまだ見てない人75版非常に長いと
思いますけども土日にずに見れば全部
見れると思います
めっちゃ無責任なことでぜひ見てみて
ください4位の巨人逸話からならず後は
まだこの土日月曜日起きるまで出ています
ので皆さんどうでしたこの選曲の巨人の
取り組みなかなかねえよ雄2羽の
チャンネルでアニメを降りと一緒に観る
っていうのがもう今までにない形だったん
でちょっと不思議な感覚ではあったんです
けども僕もは流さ縁きょうつけたんですよ
しゃべりすぎても良くないし選ばれしても
良くないし
しゃべらが過ぎても何それってなるしなん
か結構いろんなお褒めの言葉ではじめが
ちょうどいいぐらい話してくれてでよかっ
たってで打ってくれて本当にあの僕はこれ
で合ってたのかなってちょっとやりながら
不安になってたんですけど俺がいます
シャベル秒でよかったのかなっていう案に
目を邪魔せずかと言ってあの音が自分の
肝臓も出さないわけにもいかずいい感じに
視聴者さんの皆さんと進撃の巨人を楽しめ
たのかなって思いますというわけでぜひ
審議抜き始めた町2動画概要欄に市場から
75は全部リンク抜けておきます是非
[音楽]
ブービーれるよあると一緒に今日デーだ
ジャン
[音楽]
えっ
うぇっは